Speaker 1: . I got a voicemail yesterday at
two one nine two.
David Peire, actually, I guess it came in
this morning from a woman defending the coughing
and mask woman.
I did.
Even for our audience.
I never thought we would get this, but we
did.
Take a listen.
Speaker 6: Mr. Bergman, did you bother to
start to think that when you do not have a
medical degree, too, you are not a state licensed
physician?
Three, you do not know the whole entire medical
background as a patient, especially for a
woman that you write a video about at the
man?
Coughing WOMAN Yes, that's true.
Speaker 1: I'm not a doctor and I don't have
the weaponized coughers medical history so
far.
You're right,
Speaker 6: man.
Did you bother to start to think that maybe
she had COPD and that maybe she had all her
vaccinations?
Speaker 1: She may have COPD and she may be
vaccinated, but she was weaponized in her
cough against people.
So what does it matter like me?
Speaker 6: Did you bother to think about that
at all?
The pulmonologist, our pulmonologist, who
admittedly lives his faith medically licensed
venues, has the determination to make that
determination, medical evaluation and whether
or not we can wear mask at all or not.
Speaker 1: The woman herself didn't say I
have a condition and that's why I'm not wearing
a mask.
In fact, she said the opposite.
She said, I'm not sick and you're not sick.
So nobody needs masks.
And then she deliberately coughed on shoppers.
This is a delusional reaction to that video.
Speaker 6: Did not appreciate that video at
all regarding that woman
Speaker 1: who seems like you misunderstood,
is
Speaker 6: not wearing a mask because people
that do have COPD, cardio obstructive pulmonary
disease that we do cause, you know, we had
our vaccinations, everything else.
Speaker 1: But even in the video, the woman
says she has allergies.
So, I mean, this is you're wrong on every
count.
The woman said there is no medical reason
why she's for which she's not wearing a mask.
The woman said her coughing was allergies,
which was obviously a lie, and she was deliberately
coughing.
So I'm shocked anyone would defend that woman,
but somebody did.
And there in my audience, that's something
to think about.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We're going to talk about the new push by
Joe Biden and the UK to help Australia get
nuclear submarines, presumably for positioning
against China.
Very interesting geopolitical story.
We will also talk about a push by lawmakers
to get Facebook to abandon Instagram for kids,
saying there are mental health concerns with
that that proposal.
And lastly, the Justice Department, the Biden
Justice Department, headed up by Merrick Garland,
is looking for an emergency order to block
the new oppressive Texas abortion law.
All of those stories and more we will discuss
on today's phone.